[Applaus]
es gibt da eine Sache die in der ganzen
Affäre um den pregorian Putsch nicht
ganz passt du wirst inzwischen sicher
alle möglichen Analysen und unzählige
Videos zu diesem Thema gesehen haben
aber eine Frage bleibt noch offen was
hat Luca Schenker pregorcin versprochen
versetze dich für einen Moment in die
Lage des Wagner Chefs du stehst kurz
davor in Moskau 1 zu marschieren
plötzlich ruft Alexander Lukaschenka an
und sagt dreh dich um komm mit mir nach
Weißrussland und mach dir keine Sorgen
niemand wirklich töten würdest du ihm
trauen ich meine wenn es eine Sache gibt
die Wladimir Putin charakterisiert dann
ist es dass er nicht zögert seine Gegner
töten zu lassen und das ist nicht nur
metaphorisch gemeint erinnere Dich nur
an Alexander Waldi der fast vergiftet
wurde und natürlich an viele andere die
nicht so viel Glück hatten wir haben
über das heikle Thema wie das russische
Regime seine Gegner immer wieder im
Ausland umbringt sogar mal ein eigenes
Video gedreht ich werde es Dir natürlich
verlinken und wenn es eine Person gibt
die Putin jetzt am liebsten unter der
Erde sehen würde dann ist es wohl Pre
Goschen warum glaubt dieser Mann also
dass er ausgerechnet in Weißrussland
sicher ist im engsten Verbündeten
Russlands nun lasst uns mal die folgende
interessante Hypothese durchspielen was
wenn es sich um eine Meisterleistung
lukaschenkas handelt eines Gebieten
taktikers der schon viel länger an der
Macht ist als Putin und es wohl auch
noch viel länger bleiben möchte im
Moment sind wir uns ja alle einig dass
er einer der größten Nutzen dieser
dieses Putschversuch ist aber wie stark
profitiert er wirklich oder lasst es
mich etwas kühler ausdrücken was wäre
wenn Vladimir Putin in Wirklichkeit der
ahnungslose Grünschnabel in dieser
ganzen Angelegenheit war ohne es selbst
zu wissen pass auf denn im heutigen
Video werden wir vielen Hinweisen
nachgehen die von den meisten unbemer
geblieben und den Nachrichten Lärm um
die ganze Scheiße untergegangen sind und
ich garantiere dir dass du am Ende
dieses Videos den privaten Putsch mit
ganz anderen Augen sehen wirst aber sie
dir vorher bitte noch die wichtige
Botschaft unsere Sponsors blinkist an
denn die Berliner Firma Blinker hat mit
ihrem Beitrag nicht über das heutige
Video möglich gemacht nein wir nutzen
Ihre App auch selbst um täglich unseren
eigenen Wissenshorizont zu erweitern
vielleicht fragt euch ja manchmal wie
wir es überhaupt schaffen so viel Wissen
aus verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander
in unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören Artikel Analysen
Videos Podcast und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagen wissen dass notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen nun genau
dann ist man bei blinkist richtig und es
verschafft einem nicht nur mehr Zeit
sondern motiviert auch noch durch die
unterhaltsame Aufmachung blinkt es
bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5.000
Sachbüchern und Podcast auf dein Handy
und dann erlebst du einen ungeahnten
wissensbuchst anstatt Stunden in die
Lektüre eines Buches zu stecken und es
dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende zu
lesen siehst du dir in 0,nicht die immer
sehr angenehmen locker geschriebene
Blick ist Version rein man merkt dass da
echte Profis und Talente am Werk sind
stell dir vor wir würden ein wertvolles
aber langes Buch in eine knackiges und
leicht verdauliches visualpolitik Video
gießen nun genau das macht blinkist ein
Beispiel sind Bücher von Autoren mit
denen man vielleicht nicht immer einer
Meinung ist womit aber kann man seinen
Horizont besser arbeiten als mit
Informationen die eben nicht außer
eigenen Bubble stammen mir ist zum
Beispiel das Buch kein Kapitalismus ist
auch keine Lösung der ehemaligen
passautorin Ulrike Herrmann aufgefallen
gut ich habe mir natürlich gesagt taz
ist nicht gerade mein Leib und
magenblatt Rezensenten auf Amazon haben
das Buch auch dafür kritisierte
langatmig zu sein muss ich mir das also
wirklich antun andererseits hat mich
schon interessiert was da drin steht ja
und dann der Fesseln geschriebenen Blick
ist was so konnte ich innerhalb von 25
Minuten herausfinden dass dieses Werk
zumindest in der blind ist Versionen
meine Horizont durchaus bereichern
konnte solides Wissen dass ich ohne
blinke sicher verpasst hätte kurz gesagt
diese App wird hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
auch dein Leben bereichern egal für
welches Thema du dich gerade
interessierst die Auswahl und das
Spektrum sind wirklich riesig von
Finanzen über Wissenschaft Politik
Karriere bist du den klassischen
Ratgeber Themen um sein Leben zu
optimieren aber man kann mit Blick ist
nicht nur sich selbst sondern auch seine
Lieben Österreicher es hat nämlich vor
kurzem eine ganz neue Funktion namens
blinkist spaces eingeführt damit kannst
du deine lieblingsblinks mit deinen
Freunden und Kollegen teilen und
diskutieren wie in einem Buchclub und
das ist noch nicht alles
visualpolitikzuschauer bekommen über den
Link in der Beschreibung nicht nur zwei
Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von einer
seinen obendrein noch 25% Rabatt also
zögere nicht besorgt der gleich die
kostenlose 7 Tage Testversion über den
Link unter diesem Video und fangen dann
gleich damit an deinem Wissenschaft zu
bereichern und wenn du das erledigt hast
können wir sofort zur Beantwortung
unserer spannenden Fragen schreiten hat
sich Putin von Luca Schenker und
gregorien über den Tisch ziehen lassen
was ist wirklich in jedem Moment
passiert also Wagner seine Marsch auf
Moskau abbrach und nach Minz abgetreten
ist und wie wird das Dreieck Spiel
zwischen diesen macht geilen gestalten
weitergehen aufgepasst
[Musik]
eine unserer Lieblingsbeschäftigungen im
Internet ist es pro russischen
Propagandisten auf Twitter zu folgen
diese glaubt mir noch immer das Putin
ein strategisches Genie ist eine Meister
des 4d-schach und um zurechtfertigen das
Putin ein meisterstratege ist sind Sie
in der Lage wahre Purzelbäume in mentale
Gymnastik zu schlagen achte mal auf das
folgende mean das in letzter Zeit
kursiert klar jetzt stellt sich heraus
dass ihnen Wirklichkeit Putins fein
ausgeklügelten Plan verfolgt hat um 100
km von Kiew entfernt zu landen ja eine
wahre Meisterleistung wie blöd kann man
eigentlich sein wenn Putin im Wagner
Truppen an die Grenze zu Kiel fette
schicken wollen hätte er keinen Putsch
vor täuschen und seine interne Position
der entsprechenden müssen dass er
anschließend nötig hat sein Dubel in
einem Menschenmenge zu schicken und dann
wildfremden Menschen Bussis zu verteilen
außerdem was würde das für einen Sinn
machen verzeih mir dass ich ein bisschen
skeptisch bin aber welchen Sinn hätte
25.000 Soldaten quer durch eine
mittlerweile viel besser verteidigte
total vermiete Sumpflandschaft gegen
Kiew in den sicheren Tod zu schicken im
Februar 2022 haben sich die Russen beim
Sturm auf Kiew mit einer viel stärkeren
Streitmacht gegen eine schlechte
gerüstete Ukraine lächerlich gemacht
wieso sollte das Ergebnis jetzt wo die
Bedingungen für sie viel schlechter sind
anders ausfallen okay Liebe Putin Fans
ich weiß dass der Glaube Berge versetzen
kann aber das hier ist schon ein Witz
egal aus welchem Winkel man es
betrachtet es gibt einfach keine Deutung
der Prägungen Meuterei die für das Putin
Regime positiv ausfällt keine einzige
klar wir können uns darüber streiten ob
das Ganze der Ukraine Vorteile gebracht
hat oder nicht aber es ist klar dass
Putin der größte Verlierer ist aber die
Preisfrage in diesem Video ist nun wer
ist der größte Nutznießer der ganzen
Geschichte nun in diesem Fall gibt es
kaum einen Zweifel Alexander Lukaschenka
der Diktator Weißrussland er konnte sich
als der große Retter von Putins Russland
aufspielen aber Spaß wenn er in
Wirklichkeit einfach nur Putins
Kontrollverlust für sich selbst
ausgenutzt hat ein Betrüger aus
Weißrussland hat einen leichtgläubigen
russischen Rentner dazu gebracht ihm
eine private militärfirma zu überlassen
um diese Geschichte zusammenzufassen die
ganze Welt dachte immer Putin sei ein
meisterstratege ein souveräner Machertyp
der alle seine Züge weit im Voraus
geplant und daher immer alles im Griff
habe ein Schurke zwar aber ein so
gerissen sondern dass er aus jeder
erdenklichen Situation für sich selbst
den maximalen Profit schlagen kann ja
aber jetzt hat die ganze Welt live
mitverfolgen können dass er in
Wirklichkeit eine Stümper wie aus dem
Lehrbuch ist der die Kontrolle über
seine wichtigsten Untergebenen verliert
vom Kartoffel Diktator gerettet werden
muss und von diesen dabei vielleicht
auch noch über den Tisch gezogen wird
und warum behaupten wir das Luca
Schenker so sehr von diesen
Staatsstreich profitiert hat warum sagen
wir dass die Katastrophe für Putin
vielleicht noch viel größer ist als die
meisten denken und ihn im Verhältnis NIS
zu Luca Schenker als totalen Trottel da
stehen lässt all diese Fragen werden wir
heute genau untersuchen also schnallt
euch an
Diktator 100% hetero
für wenigen die nicht kennen Alexander
Lukaschenka oder russisch ausgesprochen
Lukaschenko ist der Diktator der Belarus
Seite 1994 mit eiserner Faust regiert er
ist einer der wenigen Diktatoren die
sich nicht einmal bemühen eine
demokratische Maske aufzusetzen mit
sitzen die dem folgenden hat er sogar
mit seinem diktatorischen Status geprall
es ist besser ein Diktator zu sein als
schwul und als der Krieg in der Ukraine
begann erwarteten viele dass die
weißrussische Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen
würde sie ist doch mal so Weißrussland
wurde ebenfalls vom Besten sanktioniert
beim Gegensatz zu Russland verfügt es
wieder über Gas noch Öl das hauptexport
und dieses Landes mit 9 Millionen
Einwohner ist dünner ja genau Dünger und
etwas Technologie kennst du zum Beispiel
das Video spielt World of Tanks nun es
wurde in Belarus entwickelt zumindest
war das mal so
Weißrussland größte spieleunternehmen
verlässt das Land und Russland World of
Tanks Entwickler Labor Gaming schließt
Studios und verlagert den Betrieb seine
Spiele um die eine Vorstellung zu geben
seit den Protesten 2020 haben mehr als
20.000 it Beschäftigte Belarus verlassen
diese Zahlen sind wahrlich grauenhaft
wenn man bedenkt dass es in dieser
Branche insgesamt zwischen 60 bis
100.000 Beschäftigte gibt Belarus verlor
mehr als 20% seiner qualifiziertesten
Arbeitskräfte die einzigen
Wirtschaftszweige die im Land noch am
Leben sind sind die Düngemittelindustrie
und die metallologie das Problem der
weißrösten ist jedoch wie sieht diese
Produkte überhaupt exportieren sollen
weißrussland ist ein Binnenstaat und
noch bevor der Krieg in der Ukraine
begann hatte Litauen dem Land bereits
verboten den Hafer zu benutzen
früher war dies der wichtigste
Umschlagplatz auf die größten
Absatzmärkte für russische Düngemittel
ohne ihn stand die gesamte Wirtschaft am
Rande des Zusammenbruchs in nur einem
Jahr sind die Exporte von Weißrussland
in die EU um 45% eingebrochen fünf mal
einen Blick auf diese Grafik bereits
nach der Ankündigung der Schließung des
litauensverweis Russland finden die
Währung des Landes anzusenken und dann
kam obendrein noch der russische Krieg
in der Ukraine und die Sanktion des
Westens hinzu und die Währung stürzte
total ab doch plötzlich im Juli 2022
erholt sie sich wieder wie durch einen
Wunder ja das stimmt und seither ist sie
langsam wieder gefallen natürlich haben
die Kapitalverkehrskontrollen eine
wichtige Rolle gespielt aber sie waren
nicht der einzige Schutzschild für diese
Währung
[Musik]
um dir eine Vorstellung zu geben einige
Prognosen gingen davon aus dass es BIP
von Belarus im Jahr 2022 um 10% sinken
würde der tatsächliche Rückgang betrug
jedoch nur
4,7%. das ist immer noch eine große
Krise aber es ist nicht der Abgrund den
man erwartet hatte und warum fragst du
dich vielleicht was hat Weißrussland
getan um seinem wirtschaftlichen
Armageddon zu entgehen nun wir können es
in einem Satz zusammenfassen russland
hat sein Nachbarland gerettet
ja das stimmt russland hat alles getan
um seinem Verbündeten zu helfen z.B
haben sie all ihre Hafenkapazitäten zur
Verfügung gestellt damit Minz wieder
exportieren kann und nicht nur das Luca
Schenker wird sogar seinen eigenen Hafen
auf russischen Gebiet bauen dadurch
können Sie weiterhin ihre Düngemittel in
Länder wie China und Brasilien
exportieren außerdem hat Russland im
Land sehr großzügige Kreditlinien
angeboten und als gute Verbündete hat
ist das Land auch bei Importen bevorzugt
mit anderen Worten die Russen
importieren jetzt mehr Bilder russische
Produkte als früher um genau zu sein 40%
mehr als vor dem Krieg dies hat dazu
beigetragen den Schock des Rückgangs der
Exporte in die Europäische Union auch zu
federn und große Überraschung das alles
geht mit extrem niedrigen Öl und
Gaspreisen einher um die sie ganz Europa
beneiden würde und glaubt mir diese
massiven Subventionen aus Moskau haben
alle Weißrussen in ihren Portemonnaies
zu spüren bekommen schau dir nur die
Benzinpreise an
mit anderen Worten Weißrussland hat es
schwer aber nicht so schwer wie du
vielleicht erwartet hast tja und das
alles dank Russland aber warte einen
Moment denn wir reden hier nicht nur
über die Wirtschaft Hörzu
[Musik]
ein Diktator auf tönenden Füßen
im Gegensatz zu putin wird Lukaschenko
durch eine populäre und gut organisierte
Opposition herausgefordert im Jahr 2020
hat er Wahlen abhalten lassen eine Wahl
die so betrügerisch war wie du es
erwarten würdest aber mit einem
Unterschied in diesem Fall trat auch
eine Kandidat in der Opposition gegen
lukaschenke an es wird Lana hat sie
keine Lust mehr und diese Frau schaffte
es eine oppositionsbewegungs
mobilisieren die zum Massenprotesten
gegen die Diktatur führte natürlich
reagierte lukaschenker mit der zu
erwartenden brutalen Unterdrückung
überzeuge dich selbst mit Hilfe dieser
Grafik
[Musik]
im Moment befindet sich sich Hannover
jedoch im Exil in Litauen von dort aus
organisiert sie eine sehr gut
aufgestellte Oppositionsbewegung sie
haben sogar eine App namens jubilarus
damit koordinieren sich alle weißrösten
im Exil und inzwischen verfüg
lukaschenker nicht mehr über so viel
Macht um im Falle eines ernsthaften
Aufstands seine Macht zu sichern wieso
nun zunächst einmal befindet sich die
belarussische Armee in einem ähnlich
erbärmlichen Zustand wie die ukrainische
Armee vor 2014 sowjetische Waffen jede
Menge Korruption und sehr wenige
Soldaten man schätzt dass die
belarussische Armee nur aus etwa 50.000
Mann besteht um eine Hausnummer zu
nennen und das ist noch nicht alles von
diesen Truppen sind derzeit
schätzungsweise nur 17.000 ausgebildet
und auf den Kampf vorbereitet wobei auch
das noch sehr großzügig ausgedrückt ist
viele Quellen reduzieren diese
Schätzungen sogar noch weiter auf 6000
bis 10000 Kampf gegen Soldaten bei denen
ist zu allem Überfluss noch nicht einmal
klar ist ob Sie Luca Schenker als erstes
Mal zu 100% loyal wären
[Musik]
einer der Gründe warum dieses Land keine
Truppen in die Ukraine geschickt hat ist
dass der Diktator weiß dass er nicht in
der Lage ist Druck auf seine Generäle
auszuüben ja es stimmt Weißrussland hat
russischen Truppen erlaubt durch seinen
Staatsgebiet zu ziehen aber das war es
auch schon mit der Hilfe und zur
gleichen Zeit haben die Belarussen
folgende Art von Nachrichten produziert
Rebellen in Weißrussland unterbrechen
teilweise die Eisenbahnstrecke in die
Ukraine du siehst also Lukas Schenker
kann noch nicht einmal Sabotage durch
die Opposition auf seinem eigenen
Territorium verhindern und die Frage ist
wie kann man eine Diktatur aufrecht
erhalten die auf so tönernen Füßen steht
nun die Antwort liegt in einem einzigen
Satz Putin muss ihn retten Vladimir
Putin hat angeboten den weißrussischen
Präsidenten Alexander Lukaschenka
militärisch zu unterstützen während sich
bis zu 200.000 Demonstranten versammeln
um seine Absetzung zu fördern das war
putinshilfe als lukaschenker 2020 in den
Seilen hängt aber siede an was Sie jetzt
tun Weißrussland russische Atomwaffen in
Empfang ganz genau Weißrussland befindet
sich bereits unter dem nuklearen
Schutzschirm Russlands wenn du dir
dieses Video anschaust wird Weißrussland
bereits über Atomwaffen verfügen um sein
Territorium zu verteidigen und das alles
kommt als Geschenk von Wladimir Putin
die Frage ist nur gibt es all diese
Unterstützung umsonst nun offensichtlich
nicht also wie hoch ist der Preis und
das werden wir jetzt ganz genau unter
die Lupe nehmen
wir werden eins sein irgendwann mal
[Musik]
im Jahr 1991 wurde Weißrussland von das
Sowjetunion unabhängig aber Moskau hat
nie so recht daran geglaubt dass dieses
Land lange frei und souverän sein würde
im Jahr 1999 unterzeichnete Luca
Schenker mit dem russischen Präsidenten
Bares jetzt in den Abkommen über den
sogenannten unionstaat darin wurde
vereinbart dass sich Russland und
Weißrussland eines Tages zu einem super
nationalen Gebilde namens Union Status
zusammenschließen würden der Name klingt
wie eine Art Europäische Union oder nun
ich muss dich wohl kaum davon überzeugen
dass den nicht so ist der Name ist
suggeriert etwas ähnliches eine
Vereinigung unter gleichen aber denk mal
genauer darüber nach das ist Russland
das flächenmäßig größte Land der Welt
mit mehr als 140 Millionen Einwohner
wohnen und das ist Weißrussland es
handelt es sich eindeutig um keine Ehe
unter gleichen sondern einen Vertrag der
simplen und puren und Unterwerfung
Seiten sie erziehen war es ein Versuch
Weißrussland zu einer weiteren
russischen Provinz zu der glacieren aber
warum hat ihn Luca dann damals
unterschrieben schon über eine Sache
müssen wir uns im Klaren sein
lukaschenker mag ein böser und
skrupelloser Tyrann sein aber er ist
keine Narr und er war auf jeden Fall
nicht dazu bereit seine Macht zu
verlieren ganz im Gegenteil viel mehr
spekulierte der bauernschlaue darauf
dass der Alkoholiker jelzähne sowieso
keine lange Haltbarkeitsdauer haben
würde durch das Abkommen wollte er sich
also in eine Art pulp Position um seine
Nachfolge bringen wäre sein Kalkül
aufgegangen wäre Weißrusslands war zu
einer russischen Provinz geworden er der
große lukaschenker wäre dann jedoch zum
Präsidenten große Russlands aufgestiegen
hinter dem hohen Einsatz stand also die
Aussicht auf einen noch größeren Gewinn
für ihn doch wie wir wissen ist die
Geschichte anders verlaufen als er sich
das vorgestellt hatte parallel schließt
sich nämlich die Petersburger Mafia um
einen kleinen wüstigen extra gewähler in
den Kreml ein und überzeugte den
jetzigen Plan davon die Macht an sie zu
übergeben im Gegenzug versprachen sie
ihren Straffreiheit und dass sie die
gestohlene Milliarden behalten dürfen
lukaschen war damit nicht aufgegangen
vorerst zumindest allerdings hat er
diesen Traum wohl nie wirklich
aufgegeben er musste den neuen Herrscher
im Kremmen einfach nur lange genug
hinhalten die offizielle Umsetzung einer
tatsächlichen Vereinigung bei der
Staaten hat er deswegen lange so weit
wie nur mögliche hinausgezögert Moskau
versucht im Gegenzug daher alles
Mögliche um Minsk enger an sich zu
wenden und in seine Strukturen
einzubetten
Russland unterstützt den schnellen
Beitritt von wählerrost zur Soz Russland
unterstützt den schnellstmöglichen
weiteren Weißrussland zur Shanghai
Organisation für Zusammenarbeit seit der
russische Präsident Putin auf dem
virtuellen online Gipfel der
Organisation gut das klingt ja erstmal
nicht schlecht für Weißrussland oder die
Einbindung und mit Sprache in
international Organisationen bringt der
erstmal mehr Macht und Einfluss mit sich
ja das Problem ist nur das ist Russland
eben ganz und gar nicht darum geht
seinen kleinen Nachbarn mächtiger zu
machen ganz im Gegenteil das alles ist
Teil einer rücksichtslosen Zuckerbrot
und falsche Strategie denn woran sich
nur weniger erinnern können Putin hat in
der Vergangenheit nicht nur im Falle der
Ukraine versucht ein Nachbarland durch
die Kappung von energieieferungen
gefügig zu machen Weißrussland war
ebenfalls schon das Opfer seiner
energieerpressung ganz genau Putin hat
versucht Luca Schenker mit seiner
größten wirtschaftlichen Waffe unter
Druck zu setzen Öl und Gas und der
weißrussische Diktator hat ihn sogar die
Stirn geboten indem er so weit gegangen
ist 14 Februar 2020 Weißrussland droht
dass der Europa bestimmte russische Öl
abzuschöpfen das ist richtig das ist
kein Scherz Weißrussland hat sogar damit
gedroht russisches Gas zu stehlen das
durch sein Gebiet fließt und nach Europa
transportiert wird
das alles geschah allerdings schon im
Jahr 2020 genauer gesagt vor dem
Protesten gegen Lukaschenka damals
dachte der Diktator er wäre in einer
Position der Stärke aber dann kamen
urplötzlich und ganz überraschend die
Massenproteste und in Minsk erkannte man
das ein Diktator nur dann macht hat wenn
er über militärische Stärke verfügt die
ihn im Sattel hält und als Luca Schenker
damals in den Seilen hatte er keine
andere Wahl als eben zu Putin
zurückzukriechen seitdem saß Putin
wieder am längeren Hebel und
entsprechend hat sich das Verhältnis
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern in den
letzten zwei Jahren entwickelt es
erreichte gar extreme wie diese
geliebtes Dokuments skizziert Russland
Strategie zur Annexion von Weißrussland
im Jahr 2030 wohlgemerkt der russische
Spieler russische Energie kriegt von
2020 war schon der dritte denn bereits
2004 hatte Moskau versucht Weißrussland
durch das Abdrehen des Gas hat gefügig
zu machen und dann 2017 noch einmal die
Energieabhängigkeit anderer Länder zum
Abpressen theoretischer Zugeständnis zu
nutzen war für Putin eben schon immer
ein probates Mittel allerdings der
24.06.2023 könnte jeden Punkt markieren
an dem das Publikum vom nächsten großen
Plot West in diesem jahrzehntelang
Armdrücken zwischen Putin und
Lukaschenka überrascht wurde ein
Wendepunkt den so niemand auf den Plan
hatte und dessen ganzes Ausmaß bisher
nur wenige erahnen können noch einmal
Lukaschenka mag ein real world dr evil
sein aber er ist kein Dummkopf er weiß
wie man Chancen erkennt und nutzt könnte
er also die Notlage Putins ausgenutzt
haben um sich selbst in eine Position
zurückzubringen in der er wieder den
Spieß in der Hand hält so nach dem Motto
wie du mir 2020 so ich dir 2023
schließlich kam Putin lukaschenker
damals auch oberflächlich betrachtet zu
Hilfe um ihn dann aber einen hohen Preis
dafür bezahlen zu lassen nämlich zu
einem abhängigen Befehlsempfänger und
Handlanger degradiert zu werden was
könnte die geänderte Lage also nur für
lukaschenker Putin und ganz Russland
bedeuten und was wird sie für brigoschen
bedeuten warum hatte er sich auf Luca
Schenker verlassen das alles nehmen wir
jetzt mal lieber ganz genau unter die
Lupe aufgepasst
[Musik]
wer ist hier der Trottel
am 24 Juni 2023 Raster Wagner Konvoi mit
Vollgas gehen moskau ist nur noch knapp
bei 200 km von der russischen Hauptstadt
entfernt in Kürze werden die moltern
dann bis an die Zähne bewaffneten Profis
sollten die Stadtgrenze erreicht haben
innerhalb weniger Stunden sind alle
Flüge aus Moskau ausverkauft die flight
Tracker registrieren zahlreiche
Privatjets in denen die moskovita
Oligarchie das zweite sucht und selbst
die Präsidentenmaschine mitsamt nukleare
Kommandozentrale hebt Richtung St
Petersburg ab den Moskauern egal ob
herrschende Elite oder deren Untertanen
geht mitten im Sommer der Hintern
aufgrund Eis ihr eigener Krieg der lange
weit von ihnen entfernt war scheint zu
ihnen gekommen zu sein ganz genau sie
haben Angst vor dem was der Beginn eines
Bürgerkrieg sein könnte die Rede ist von
angeblich fast 25000 erprobten
rebellierenden sollten an die in
Windeseile hunderte Kilometer durch
russisches Territorium vorrücken wie ein
heißes Messer durch ein Stück Butter
unterwegs schießen sie mir nichts Armee
Hubschrauber und Flugzeuge ab die
scheinen sich wie in ihrem Element zu
fühlen als würde ihnen bereits das ganze
Land gehören hätten sie Moskau wirklich
komplett einnehmen können nun
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht es handelt
sich schließlich um eine riesige
Metropole mit über 10 Millionen
Einwohnern aber es ist klar dass es ein
echtes Blutbad gegeben hätte wenn Sie
Ihren macht fortgesetzt und es darauf
hätten ankommen lassen und in diesem
Moment als Putin Schicksal am seinen
Faden zu hängen Schienen passierte
folgendes was du jetzt hören wirst ist
wortwörtlich das Telefongespräch das
Lukaschenko nach eigenen Angaben mit
Putin geführt hat komm schon wo Leute ja
wie wollt ihr die Meuterer liquidieren
lasst uns mitbringen und sein
Kommandeuren sprechen Sie mal Sascha er
nimmt nicht einmal den Hörer ab er will
nicht mehr mit mir reden tja und dann
nimmt Luca Schenker sein Handy und ruf
brigoch schön einfach selbst an Minuten
später sagt dann Prickeln das Wagner
seine Reise nach Moskau abbrechen und
Richtung wählerhaus abdrehen wird
Lukaschenko und Putin haben einen Deal
geschlossen der für jeden von ihnen im
gegebenen Moment als der beste Ausweg
ziehen und Stunden später verkündete der
Kreml das folgende Russland stellt
Strafverfahren gegen pregorsche nach
Wagner Rebellion ein wo die zwei großen
Fragen die sich alle gestellt haben
lauteten natürlich erstens warum wählte
Putin überhaupt Luger Schenker als
seinen Unterhändler wieso hatte er es
nötig ihm dadurch so viel Macht zu
verleihen und zweitens wieso ließ sich
Pre Goschen ausgerechnet von Luca
Schenker überreden wieso traut er seinen
Sicherheitsgarantien in Belarus nun die
erste Frage ist schnell geklärt putin
hatte wohl keine andere Wahl er hatte
sich durch seinen harten kurze sämtliche
Alternativen beraubt
ab Februar 2023 hatte er begonnen Wagner
die Daumenschrauben anzuziehen und im
Juni gab es im ersten siebten die
komplette Absorption des Soldaten
mehr angeordnet das war übrigens wie
auch die Kommandeure seiner
professionellen Truppe absolut
inakzeptabel hatten einfach zu hoch
gegen sie gepokert und verloren und als
Brigitte geben wollte sondern zum
frontal Angriff Übergängen wie es eben
seine Art ist deklarierte in Putin auch
noch als Verräter der hat bestraft
werden müssen das war schon die zweite
Sackgasse aus der sich Putin nur schwer
ohne Gesichtsverlust hätte heraus
manövrieren können er sah also entweder
einem Blutbad in Moskau entgegen oder
schlimmstenfalls eine absoluten
Demütigung seiner Macht also sagte er
sich das ist für ihn wohl besser wäre
gregion durch Konzession durch einen
Kompromiss erstmal zu besinnigen und
damit das Schlimmste vorerst abzuwenden
seine Hoffnung wenn es nicht zu einem
Totalschaden kommt kann man im
Nachhinein die Schäden ja immer
irgendwie reparieren die Geschichte
umdeuten sich hinterrücksrechen und so
weiter und so fort das Problem war nur
das Hauptforderung nämlich schon gut aus
zu man konnte Punkt dir nicht erfüllen
er musste ihn also irgendwas anderes
versprechen und um dieses Angebot auch
irgendwie glaubhaft garantieren können
die Idee war also im anzubieten dass er
die Kontrolle über Wagner behalten darf
zumindest über den harten Kern aber das
nächste Problem war welche glaubhaften
Sicherheitsgarantien würde man pregorien
gehen können damit er einem das ganze
abkauft nun an dieser Stelle kam Luka
schenka ins Spiel wieso nun dies hängt
mit der zweiten Frage zusammen zwischen
Prägung und lukaschenker herrscht
nämlich ein jahrelanges tiefes
Vertrauensverhältnis hör dir mal an was
der Kartoffel Diktator bereits im Jahr
2020 über den Wagen etwas gesagt hat z.B
waren die sie erwähnt haben ihr wissen
wer diese Organisation anführt jenja
gregorchini ich ihn ja Sie können sich
nicht mal vorstellen er und ich haben
das beste Verhältnis zueinander das
beste lukaschen Angebote für beide
Streit haben
die beste Option da ihre ineinander
verhackten Hörner wieder auseinander zu
bekommen beide braucht ihn gerade zu in
diesem Moment lukaschen Zipfel des
Mantels der Geschichte in Griffweite und
langte ordentlich zu in den nächsten
Tagen tauchte brigoshi erstmal unter
gleichzeitig sagt Russland dass alle
Wagner Söldner die nicht an der moderat
beteiligt waren in die reguläre Armee
aufgenommen würden aber bedenke bitte
das bregor schön zum Zeitpunkt des
Putsches zwischen 20 und 25.000 Mann
unter seinem Kommando hatte gut 8000
davon soll nun also in Weißrussland
stationiert werden und dabei dürfte es
sich um den harten Kern der Drucker
handeln die krähender Krems
natürlich wirst du dich fragen können
Söldner überhaupt loyal sein ich meine
sie tun das alles ja nur für Geld wer
ihnen mehr bietet für den Kämpfen sie
dann doch nun nicht unbedingt
wahrscheinlich können sie viel loyaler
sein als wir uns denken zum einen haben
sie gregorien natürlich bei seinem
Putschversuch unterstützt aber denk auch
mal über folgendes nach rigorien hat
ehemalige Offiziere der russischen
astronomische Gehälter bezahlt er hat
ihnen eine viel bessere Führungsstruktur
und Führungskultur geboten er hat auch
ehemalige sträflinger Rekrut und du
wirst dich fragen kann ein
ex-sträflingen loyal sein die Antwort
lautet ja sehr sogar wir reden hier über
Menschen deren Leben quasi vorbeischehen
den nichts anderes übrig blieb als bis
zu ihrem Tod in einem russischen Knast
zu verrotten Menschen ohne Familie und
ohne Zukunft den prägossen eine zweite
Chance Boot die Chance vom kriminellen
Abschaum zum Helden des Vaterlands zu
werden im Laufe der Geschichte haben wir
viele Elitetruppen gesehen die mit einer
sehr ähnlichen Philosophie aufgestellt
worden mit anderen Worten Pre Goschen
wusste genau was er tat als er sein
sollte und natürlich weiß das auch Luca
Schenker deswegen empfängt er ihn nicht
nur als den Anführer der wagnertruppe
mit offenen Armen sondern auch seine
gesamte autorage und die Wahrheit ist
nun mal dass er recht hat und zwar mehr
als er selbst zugibt sie werden uns von
den Waffen erzählen welche gut
funktionieren welche nicht von Taktik
und Waffen und wie man angreift wie man
sich verteidigt das ist von
unschätzbarem Wert das ist es was wir
von den vaginaten übernehmen müssen sie
werden den Interessen nicht nur
beibringen im Waffen und Taktiken
anzuwenden sondern auch Folter Mord und
Führung und Vergewaltigung gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung malische Truppen und
mutmaßlich russische Kämpfer werden für
Massaker verantwortlich gemacht es gibt
erschütternde Berichte über malische
Truppen und mutmaßlich russische Söldner
die im Zentrum Marlies etwa 300 Menschen
hingerichtet haben sollen die Wagner
Söldner sind echte Bestien
verantwortlich für die grausamsten
Folterungen die man sich nur vorstellen
kann und so makaber es klingt mit Hilfe
ihrer schrecklichen Praktiken konnten
sie für ihre Auftraggeber und sich
selbst beachtliche Erfolge in Syrien und
Afrika erzielen und sie waren seit über
einem Jahr praktisch die einzigen die in
der Ukraine einen Sieg für die russische
Seite erringen konnten genau das erklärt
danach Nachrichten wie diese Belarus
baut Lager für ungesiedelte Wagner
Mitglieder du siehst Lukaschenko
verschwendet keine Zeit das erste dieser
lagerverfahren
200 km von der Grenze zur Ukraine
entfernt es wird angeblich bis zu 8000
Zöllner beherbergen und lukaschenke hat
angeblich Wagner nun sogar erlaubt in
weiß Russland neue Kämpfer anzuwerden
gut einige werden sich fragen woher
Belarus überhaupt das Geld für den
Unterhalt dieser Krieger nehmen will
denn wer so ohne die Verträge die Wagner
mit dem Gremmel hatte ihre gehälteren
Zahlen
nun wenn du visualpolitik schon länger
verfolgst weißt du bereits das Wagner
nicht nur in der Ukraine aktiv ist er
ist auch in Afrika sehr aktiv wo er
nicht nur mit Geld sondern auch mit
Sachleistungen bezahlt wird Wagner
kontrolliert dort mehrere Minen mit
laufenden Aktivitäten im Kamerun wo
China Faso ecutorial Guinea Südafrika
sind Bafög und Kenia ist der Wagner in
Afrika sehr präsent wir reden hier über
Gold und andere Ressourcen im Wert von
Milliarden von Dollar zwar versucht der
Kreml nur in diese Operation und die
damit verbundenen Geldströme unter seine
direkte Kontrolle zu bekommen aber ob
Putin ist wirklich gelingen kann ist
noch offen zum einen sind die dortigen
Söldner wie gesagt überaus loyal gegen
patrikaschinen und wollen nicht unter
dem Kommando einer stur behaften
thermischen Militärführung verheißt
werden die Gräben zwischen Wagner und
Schulbus Verteidigungsministerium sind
unglaublich tief
und falls die wagnerkommandeure und
sollte in der mittleren Ebene pregorian
treu bleiben könnte die Einsetzung neuer
camel-treuer Kommandeure gewaltig in die
Hose gehen rigorien wird von den
wagnerkämpfern nach wie vor verehrt und
viele von ihnen könnten sich an der
Aussicht auf eine neue Führung oder eine
drastische Veränderung der
Organisationskultur stoßen und zum
anderen könnten auch die Kunden also die
regins in Afrika ein großes Problem
bekommen wenn sie statt von Ihnen
beauftragten neutralen sollten an und
plötzliche russische Soldaten im Land
haben die direkt aus Moskau kommentiert
werden die Traumata aus der Kolonialzeit
sind groß man will nicht die Truppen
fremder Staaten auf eigene Territorium
haben jeder Herrscher oder Bohrloch der
dies zulässt macht sich gegenüber seinen
Rivalen angreifbar und so guter Letzt
sollte man nicht vergessen dass selbst
wenn es putinellänge prägossen Geld
Ströme Zukunft zu unterbrechen dies
nicht die vielen Milliarden betrifft mit
denen er in der Vergangenheit seine
Taschen voll gestopft hat pregorien wird
sicher schlau genug gewesen sein diese
gut zu bunkern eben verhafte Zeiten wie
jetzt
10 Milliarden hobelbar Geld und weitere
beschlagnahmen
zurück gregosch ins Fahrer dem eine
Vollmacht erteilt worden war holte das
Geld am 2 juli ab insgesamt 10
Milliarden Rubel das sind 111 Millionen
Dollar und Hunderttausende von Dollar in
bar sowie 5 Goldbarren die Ermittler
wollten das beschlagnah der Eigentum
zunächst nicht zurückgeben aber nach
dieser erneuten Wendung zu urteilen hat
eine höhere Macht eingegriffen eines ist
klar Pre Goschen wird sich auf keinen
Fall unterkriegen lassen er wird dafür
sorgen weiterhin sowohl für Putin als
jetzt auch für Luca Schenker nützlich zu
sein oder dabei aber seine eigene Agenda
aus den Augen zu verlieren alle drei
Putin Prägungen treiben jeweils ein
dynamisches Teiler und herrscherspiel
miteinander und natürlich mit vielen
anderen
Wagner bossin taucht nach Exil in
Weißrussland endlich wieder auf der Wall
of verteidigte den Putschversuch gegen
die russische Regierung im vergangenen
Monat und rief die Öffentlichkeit auf
seine Armee zu unterstützen ich möchte
dass ihr versteht das unser Marshall
Gerechtigkeit dazu diente die Verräter
zu bekämpfen und unsere Gesellschaft zu
mobilisieren ich denke das ist uns in
vielen Punkten gelungen ich bin mir
sicher dass ihr nahezukunft unseren
nächsten Siege an davon sehen werdet
danke Leute also weiterhin versuchen
sowohl seine Polarität innerhalb der
Bevölkerung auszubauen als auch
potenzierte Putin nützlich zu bleiben
als Joker im Ukraine Feldzug und was
bringt er sogar Schenker nun was
brauchte dieser um von unabhängiger zu
werden ganz genau militärische Stärke
[Musik]
vorhin haben wir gesagt das Weißrussland
nur über eine Armee von weniger als
50.000 aktiven Mann verfügt und dass
diese schlecht ausgebildet und bewaffnet
sind und jetzt haben sie gerade
mindestens 8000 Kampf erfahren und gut
ausgebildete Elitetruppen erhalten und
ich weiß welche Frage als nächstes kommt
wer sagt denn das brigochian lukasche
gegenüber loyal sein wird nun die
Antwort lautet die Umstände Wagner kann
nach all dem was geschehen ist nicht
einfach so zurück nach Russland gehen
braucht für seine Business aber eine
stabile Operationsbasis und dafür kommen
nur wenige Länder in Frage und in kaum
einem anderen dürfte er sicherer sein
als in Weißrussland die brutale
wagnergruppe und belauscht sind der
perfekte Mensch schließlich handelt es
sich um das letzte Land in Europa das
noch die Todesstrafe anwendet mit
anderen Worten Lukas Schenker und
brigochen haben vorerst sehr gute Gründe
sich zu vertragen und Putin wiederum
braucht Lukas Schenker um die beste
namens Wagner die er selbst erschaffen
liest irgendwie einzulegen denn
andererseits wäre es für ihn auch Christ
sofort zu liquidieren erstens könnte er
ihn dadurch zum Märtyrer machen vor
einem solchen Schritt müsste Putin
irgendwie dafür sorgen dass pregosch ins
hohe Popularität in weiten Teil der
russischen Bevölkerung als auch dem
Militär sinkt zweitens könnte es
natürlich sein dass Putin pregorians
Dienste mit Wagner und seine
Führungskompetenz noch irgendwann im
Krieg gegen die Ukraine und anderswo
brauchen wird keine andere Gruppierung
genießt ein ähnliches Ansehen bei den
russischen Nationalisten und den Russen
die den Krieger der Ukraine befürworten
niemand reicht an die Reputation Wagners
und Gregorian schon gar nicht die Armee
und das gilt auch für das Portfolio und
Fähigkeiten die Wagner für den Kreml bei
der Durchführung einer Vielzahl von
außenpolitischen Aktivitäten und
verzichtbar machen tja nach allem was
wir gesehen haben ist also vor allem
eines klar Putin hat sich erst vom
nützlichen Biest Wagner abhängig gemacht
dann die Kontrolle darüber verloren und
um sich anschließend Luft zum Atmen zu
verschaffen ist da auch noch zu Luca
schenkas Trottel geworden erst hatte
eben Geld und politische Unterstützung
gegeben dann hat er im Atomwaffen
geschickt jetzt hat er ihm eine privat
gegeben und eine verdammt mächtige dazu
Kämpfer der Gruppe Wagner äußern sich
nach Meuterei Weißrussland wird die
kampfstärkste Einheit der Welt haben
natürlich ist Weißrussland nach wie vor
wirtschaftlich extrem abhängig von
Russland aber seine Verhandlungsposition
hat sich entscheidend verbessert und wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass zwischen
Luca Schenker und Putin wahrlich keine
Liebesbeziehung besteht siehe die sich
immer wieder wiederholende
energieerpressung Weißrussland durch den
Kreml deswegen Verstand ist Luca
Schenker in der Vergangenheit immer sehr
geschickt opportunistisch zwischen den
Kreml und der EU zu jonglieren und für
sich das Maximum aus beiden Beziehungen
herauszuholen erst nach 2020 musste er
sich ziemlich Knirschen endgültig Putin
Fuchtel unterordnen nun ja ob dies aber
wirklich endgültig war wird sich noch
zeigen falls Putin nämlich untergeht
wird Lukaschenka sofort wieder die Seite
wechseln um an der Macht zu bleiben und
Russland als Handelspartner zu ersetzen
oder er wird gar versuchen sich seinen
lebenslangen Traum zu erfüllen und
endlich auch die Macht in Moskau an sich
zu reißen vielleicht wird Russland zu
einem Teil Weißrusslands werden wer weiß
wie die Dinge ausgehen ihr seht die Lage
ist hochgradig dynamisch und die
Entwicklung bleibt verdammt spannend
deswegen werden wir euch auch weiterhin
mit viel informativen Videos über dieses
Thema versorgen und aus diesem Grund
solltet ihr auch unseren Kanal abonniert
haben natürlich unbedingt mit Glöckchen
so und nun hätte ich noch ein paar
wichtige Fragen an euch was meint ihr
ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit wann die
Spannungen zwischen Russland und
Weißrussland wieder aufnahmen werden wie
könnte Putin versuchen sich aus seiner
misslichen Lage heraus zu Manieren auf
welche Weise kann er die Zahl seine
Optionen in seinem ewigen Teile und
herrscherspiel wieder erhöhen was
würdest du an seiner Stelle tun sollte
er eher versuchen bringt euch hinzu
liquidieren oder zu rehabilitieren und
wer sitzt im Moment am längeren Hebel
Putin oder lukaschenker wie immer sind
wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like heißt
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihm natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns halt
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald